Tabitha is in Charlotte North Carolina
hi Tabitha how are you hi I'm good
how can I help okay so we just have been
listening to you non-stop on YouTube my
husband I found you and basically I'd
hear your name were then I hear my name
from house so we are trying to get some
of our debt taken care of about a year
ago my husband lost his job and it's
making a lot less money and we just kind
of been fumbling and struggling through
the last year what did he use to make
that we used to make 70 what you might
know he makes about around 80
I'm sorry around 41 you see 40 1600 so
everything why do you want to take such
a pay cut well they let him go and his
other jobs so he went into another and
he though he was stores cars so he went
into the same kind of line of work but
just the local place that we hire around
here we're kind of in a very small town
and that's it just didn't pay there in
college so that's what we you know it's
like we can't afford to move to go
someplace where you know he can make
more money or like that right now so
we're just kind of trying to get through
it right now for $30,000 a year you
can't afford not to move yeah because if
he can make eighty one place and makes
40 another place that's time to be at
the other place yeah so that's an
intimate show yes it is and because of
that we've had the drops and bills just
recently and so that we could we were
stretching ourselves out from his other
job we had a little bit of leftover we
had some few thousand dollars in the
bank and that kind of carried us through
and now we're completely out and I my
health went downhill over the last year
I have adrenal insufficiency so I cannot
work right now and so it's been a big
struggle because now we're tied to less
and bills go and that's why I'm calling
you to kind of
he you know so not much do well here how
much do in your cars we have two cars
that are paid off what are their totals
but they drive
they're both totaled and Halestorm used
to live in Colorado and so they're worth
hasn't looked a mother hoser dollars
each other no they're not another point
so what bills have you got there
we have we have our house we're paying
on its $165,000 on the loans and then we
have $30,000 of debt which is a 20,000
of credit cards type line of credit type
stuff and then 10,000 of medical bills
okay this is an income issue isn't it
[Music]
and so if he's going to stay in that
line of work and he cannot make 80,000
in your town you need to be in a
different town you won't be happy to
hear that but I'm happy you can't just
sit here and act like these numbers you
can't put your hands over yours and go
lalala and make the math Jay the math is
not going to change until you change it
but I don't mean if he can make 81 I
don't understand is how he was making 75
or 80 in the same field in the same town
but now he can't actually traveling and
it was not travelling about commuting
and he was doing race cars and he does
car serration but he's done both and so
then he's now in a we're a smaller area
and he's just doing the restoration and
that's just what's around here yeah but
yes so what what is he gonna do to get
his income up does he have to move does
he have to go back to race cars and
getaway from restoration does he have to
do both what's he gonna do to get income
up I would say that we definitely need
to move okay you have nothing in our
savings so right now so and we've
dropped some bills and we're that's not
a good thing but we've dropping the
bills doesn't scare me it's not dealing
with causing one it's not dealing with
the cause of the bills being dropped it
scares me you can't just sit there and
look at this and think it's
change you got to do something to get
your income up and the thing is he has
the ability to make the money and so I
don't care if he takes a temporary job
going on the road with race car team
building race cars for two years and you
know he's gonna be gone a bunch but it's
not going what he wants to do the rest
of his life I don't want to travel like
that but for two years I got to do that
get my house straightened up here or we
gotta move to a town where I can just be
a restoration high-end mechanic and make
80 grand which actually you could do in
a metro area I mean of is EAA was a ESC
what do you call it certified no he's
not self-taught and has just he's really
good at what he does so he's been doing
a lot of custom stuff it sounds like
okay right and exactly and that's
obviously like if you're depending on
the area you know you either get really
high rollers or you don't have you know
much going so yeah you're gonna have to
get to a market where there's guys are
people they're willing to pay that to
work on a car let me work on specialty
cars what it amounts to
or he's gonna have to move back towards
the racecar side of the equation I don't
care which one you do but all I'm
telling you is is you have a math
problem and the only way to solve the
math problem is with his income because
you're not able to work that's what you
told me and so this is not going to go
away until you address that issue hey
thanks for the call